if you're worn out on games with drab
pallets and dramatic characters and
sunset overdrive it's just the game you
need to lift your spirits
it's a liberating experience that trades
in rules and drama for freedom and pure
unadulterated enjoyment and it never
pretends to be anything but an excuse to
swear like a sailor jump off a
skyscraper and blow up a gang of
monsters
it's the end of days after the evil
energy drink corporation Fisk Oh
poisoned almost the entire population of
Sunset city turning them into violent
rage beasts known as OD it's up to you
to kill the Horde and liberate the city
but before your crusade kicks off you
get to create a character if you're
choosing from a wide variety of silly
creative options make no mistake sunset
overdrive is immature on all fronts
nearly every character swears up a storm
dropping f-bombs like it's going out of
style
however unlike many games that take this
approach the vulgarity never feels
forced and it reinforces the attitude
that permeates the game am i right but
seriously those [ __ ] od will
tell you apart be careful
sunset city is large dense with
buildings and artifacts with plenty of
variation in architectural style
everything's coated in a bright
saturated coat of paint keeping the game
a Pixar light quality that's easy to
love when you're in the midst of battle
sometimes with what seems like 100
enemies the screen fills with explosions
bursts of lightning and bright green
ooze of course when you're zipping
across town you're going to miss a few
the finer details but you'll be having
too much fun to care one of Sunset
OverDrive's core mechanics is its
mobility system which allows you to
grind on almost everything
jump incredibly high and eventually walk
on water stringing movements together
not only gets you to your destination
safely and quickly but it really
communicates what sunset overdrive is
all about pure enjoyment sometimes you
slightly miss your mark but that's okay
because the game is very forgiving when
it comes to time once you get the hang
of each movement you can free run from
one end of the city to the other without
ever touching the ground and it's a
wonderful feeling you must explore every
nook and cranny just like you wouldn't
crackdown in order to find collectables
that go towards amps powers that boost
your abilities but you can make it
easier on yourself by purchasing maps
that pinpoint their locations as you
perform certain actions such as grinding
using automatic weapons or air dashing
you earn badges that can be traded in
for other power-ups as well sunset
overdrive is weapon options are numerous
and wild and varied enough to keep you
entertained well beyond the end of the
main mission paths you start out simply
enough with an automatic record gun in
the shotgun that sets enemies on fire
but by the end of the game you've got an
acid sprinkler a bowling ball cannon and
explosive teddy bear launcher and a gun
that bombards enemies with fireworks and
illusionary
Chinese dragons at the start it feels
like all you're doing are fetch quests
it definitely helps that moving and
shooting are so fun but you still pine
for something different after the
doesn't fetch quest in a row give it
time however and you'll discover a wider
variety of challenges including a hefty
dose of environmental traversal
challenges and combat scenarios that
keep you entertained there are also more
than a few great boss battles that
challenge your ability to act quickly
and move effectively and these are some
of the best moments in the game just me
think you're on the verge of boredom a
crazy over-the-top mission appears
reigniting your enthusiasm of course at
some point the main storyline comes to
an end and though you can freely replay
any mission in the game at a moment's
notice you should jump online and screw
around sunset city with your friends hop
into the chaos squad boots around the
map and you and a team of seven other
warriors can tackle horde like throngs
of enemies defend outposts and put your
traversal skills to the test
it is difficult with a party of less
than 8 people which may prove
problematic for some that only want to
play with a small group of friends
insomniac games is crafted an excellent
game and sunset overdrive it's not
without a few niggling issues but you'll
be too busy enjoying yourself to care
playing it makes you feel like a
super-powered kid in a candy store in a
playground you can compare it to games
like crackdown Tony Hawk's Pro Skater or
Ratchet and Clank but by combining the
best of those elements from those games
into a single package and injecting it
with an anything-goes rock and roll
attitude you never think of it as
anything but a singular achievement that
stands tall in its own merits it's
easily one of the best games on the Xbox
one and a refreshing shot of mirror